Express d times 4d to the
fourth to the 1/2 power
as a radical expression.
So the key thing
to realize here is
that if I take anything to
the 1/2 power, by definition,
this is the same thing as
taking the principal root
of that anything.
So let's just apply that here.
We have 4d to the fourth
raised to the 1/2 power.
So this part right
over here-- let
me do it in two
different colors.
So I have d right over there.
And then I have 4d to the
fourth raised to the 1/2 power,
which, by definition, is
the principal root of 4d
to the fourth.
And we explore in other videos
why this all works out well
with exponent properties.
And we know how to
simplify this right here.
We're looking for
the principal root
of-- let me write it this way.
This is the same thing as
d times the principal root
of 4 times the principal
root of d to the fourth.
The principal root of 4 is 2.
And we have that d out front.
And the principal root
of d to the fourth power
can be viewed as the positive
square root of d to the fourth,
and that is d squared.
And we don't have to put
an absolute value here
because even if d
is a negative value,
d squared will still
be a positive value.
If this was a d
squared here, then we
would have to think about the
absolute value right over here.
And then just to simplify this,
we have a d times a 2 times
a d squared.
That's-- multiply the d's
times each other, same base--
that becomes d to the third.
So this becomes 2 times
d to the third power.
Now, another way you
could have done this
is to just straight use
the exponent properties.
You could have said that that
is the same thing as d times--
and inside the parentheses, if
you take the product of things
and then raise them
to an exponent, that's
the same thing as
raising each of them
individually to the exponent
and then taking the product.
So that's the same
thing-- so I'm
going to rewrite this
part right over here
as 4 to the 1/2 power times d
to the fourth to the 1/2 power.
And 4 to the 1/2 power,
this is literally just
the principal square
root of 4, which is 2.
And d to the fourth
to the 1/2 power.
This is, again, you can
use an exponent property.
If I have something
raised to some power
and then I have it
raised to another power,
this is the same thing
as that same base raised
to the product of these powers.
And we prove it in other videos.
So this right over here, this
expression right over here
is going to be equal to d
to the 4 times 1/2 power.
Well, what's 4 times 1/2?
Well, that's just 2.
So this simplifies, once again,
to d times 2 times d squared,
which is 2d to the third power.